as well  if you manage to it's what he said one  day if you manage to surprise your  seconds then you are you are doing well  uh yeah that's very good there should be  anybody as anybody is sort of main goal  in life first acquire second then  surprise seconds with the opening  choices you know dot dot dot profit and  then yeah I mean it's a good test you  know I said if so much to supply the  second then very likely you will  surprise your parents so let's see yeah  I guess that's the game of the day even  if anonymity of his um  it's a classical uh obviously absolutely  yeah and first game another way to  you know be pleasantly surprised is by  by checking your chat messages  apparently which is yeah read chat long  is is the first thing you got to do  second thing we're going to do let's  talk about the wind